bring in our panel a little bit early to
deal with the big news of this day let's
bring them and byron york chief
political correspondent of the
Washington Examiner Josh Crouch our
political editor for the National Review
and matthew cottan Ettie editor-in-chief
of the washington free beacon gentlemen
thanks for coming in Byron your thoughts
it doesn't seem like this is any
different than what was on the table a
while ago it is not this this shutdown
was over a border barrier the president
demanded that Congress had to give him
money for the barrier or else he would
keep the government shut
now he's agreed to reopen the government
without getting any money for the border
barrier so the short version is Pelosi
won and Trump lost now the White House
in its defense says that they believe
there are a number of Democrats on
Capitol Hill who would actually approve
money for a border Berrien barrier and
that's right there really are such
Democrats but the leadership Nancy
Pelosi has not changed her absolutely
nothing for the wall position she has
not changed her position that walls are
quote amoral and by not giving an inch
she has just won so it's not clear why
the White House thinks that after
winning she would now start making
concessions Josh I apologize I said
National Review it's National Journal of
course your thoughts on this day well
look the first rule of government
shutdowns is you can never hold the
government hostage for any favored
legislative priority and Democrats
learned it the hard way with daca and
then they took the political blame
earlier last year for trying to hold the
government hostage because of taka and
Republicans the president Trump running
it because of border security the
national polls are really really tough
for the white house 37 percent job
approval 50 disapproval in the mid to
upper 50s in all the national polls in
our Fox poll Democrats had a ten-point
advantage on border security that hardly
ever happens so president Trump knew he
had to fold at least for now and punt
til the politics turned a little bit
more favorably for Republicans here are
the Senate leaders Democrat and
Republican Democrats are against the
wall but we agree on many things such as
the need for new technology and the need
to strengthen security at our ports of
tree and that bodes well for coming to
an eventual agreement the days ahead
will tell us whether our Democratic
colleagues are actually serious about
securing our nation whether they
actually mean what they say
so the question Matthew is whether the
base the president's base is really
turned off by this move by the president
the pressure obviously had gotten to a
very high point that's right and
President Trump has to both worry about
his base and worry about the rest of the
country and there was the rest of the
country I think that had turned against
him on the shutdown that was against the
wall when you asked him just directly
are you for the wall
most Americans are against that and so
President Trump was fighting against the
most powerful force in American politics
it's not Nancy Pelosi it's public
opinion but I think the White House
should look at this as an opportunity
breath to really kind of begin to turn
the ship around and head toward
re-election in 2020 there is a deal to
be made
and even though Schumer is adamantly
against the wall' Pelosi and her press
conference today actually was very vague
about what might be included in this
deal from the conference committee
there's the opportunity I think to get
some of these freshmen Democrats who
came to Washington with their voters
expecting them to solve problems to back
some type of barrier it might not be the
wall of president Trump's dreams but all
he needs is a little bit in order to
please his constituents heading into
re-election right so Byron is the the
immediate win Nancy Pelosi's is the
potential for a long-term win on border
security for the president and the
administration there is still that
possibility it is possible that without
the pressure of government being shut
down and all the problems that caused
without that pressure perhaps people
could take a more sober look at the
president's last proposal which in
addition to money for a boarder barrier
included all sorts of things that both
party likes more technology to detect
drugs at ports of entry humanitarian aid
more beds at the detention centers more
immigration judges all the sorts of
things that were part of a package that
both parties
in the past prior to Trump would
actually support and that would include
a physical barrier at the border always
part of that so perhaps it's possible
that when all the craziness of the
shutdown is over people could take
another look at that proposal Josh we're
hearing from our producer up on Capitol
Hill chat program that too soon to do
the State of the Union on Tuesday they
believe but they're floating February
5th clearly the president wanted to
deliver the State of the Union address
in the House chamber with all the pomp
and circumstance look the State of the
Union whenever it's scheduled is going
to be president Trump's opportunity to
get some political momentum back and
took to Byron's point Republicans win
the immigration argument when it's
broadly about border security it's when
Trump kind of got caught up in the wall
we need to have this for the wall that
really put him and the Republicans in
Congress in a corner and even he backed
off from that you know saying it was
really just four steel slats or four a
combination of border security measures
Trump needs to reset his immigration
agenda his border security agenda with
the State of the Union but he has to
think more broadly he can't just be
speaking to the the 30% 35% base he has
to look at the broad majority of the
country that does want solid border
enforcement in the meantime Matthew
Democrats are relishing the fact that
they're tweaking the president with
Nancy Pelosi suggesting that she's the
big winner here you have representative
Karen bass tweeting out that speaker
Pelosi should give the State of the
Union address and she's obviously the
one running the country well Karen bass
is wrong the president is still the
president he has all the powers of the
office you look at some of the things
he's done on foreign policy for example
you see the immense power of the
presidency Nancy Pelosi is an extremely
savvy legislator and she knew she had a
winning hand especially when President
Trump in December said that he would
take the credit or blame if the
government shut down well that's what
happened and the public listened to
President Trump and they blamed him but
now I think is an opportunity to try to
not only reset the immigration debate as
Josh said they really start thinking
seriously and strategically about what
it will take to expand his support to
get win him reelection in 2020
all right gentlemen thank you we'll see
you later in the show